the rays on a pathway to a hundred wins
this year and they send luis coutinho to
the mound petinio with a record of 4-3
will be making his 16th appearance he
will face a kill badou to start be nice
to see tigers get on the board in the
first inning we haven't done that in a
while
and badou delivers to deep right field
jack you called it him
delivered
just like last night
diaz homered for tampa bay and tonight
akil badu he's got to be excited about
that that'll get the boys fired up down
there 13th homer of the year for aquil
badu big smile on his face tigers have
the early lead
swing and a miss 97 up
and he throws that one by
jonathan scott
the 1-1 is chopped to third
that's a fair ball
got a big field single for miguel
cabrera one hit closer to 3 000.
fly ball
center field
keermeyer toward left center for this
one grabs it one run on the badoo home
run a man left and casey mize is out
there it's the 28th time he's starting
for the tigers back-to-back starts
against tampa he'd like to improve upon
his last one where he only went two
innings
swings the loops one into the shallow
center that gets down for a base hit
nico goodream the shortstop on the shift
made a move forward and realized it was
beyond his reach
liner base head into left
grossman cutting to his right now choi
is going to go to third and into second
base follows a rose arena choi
rounded the bag took a peek actually
slowed down and then wound up moving up
to third
there's a liner into right
reyes will make the catch the tag by
choi
he will score
over to third goes to rose arena the
rays tie it and that's a hundred runs
batted in
for austin meadows he's the first raid
to do that since 2010 evan longoria it's
been a long time coming and he gets it
done and out of the way early
the one two
swinging a little pop fly down the left
field line slicing and that ball is fair
right on the line to rosarino fielded in
foul territory castro legging it out to
second the throw is offline he'll go in
standing up little flare double harold
castro starts the second inning in
scrolling position
the o2
ripped to right field into the corner
another extra base hit
castro will score goodram is into second
base with a head first slide in an rbi
double the tigers reclaim the lead that
ball was hit hard and in the right spot
harold can pretty much jog around the
bases as nico goes into second base
reyes with a ground ball to second nice
play by lau but he can't come home with
it
he was knocked down a little bit on the
play and nico goodwin was running on
contact reyes drives in the tigers third
run of the night they beat by two here's
miguel cabrera
cabrera first pitch swinging in a base
hit to left second hit of the night for
miguel cabrera getting closer now 22 shy
of 3 000. two on one out tigers leading
by two in the third the pitch swing a
little pop line to ride and it's gonna
drop over the head of brandon now
running through it and holding robbie
grossman and the bases are now loaded
with one out you like him at the plate
right here because he's a contact guy he
doesn't strike out much
first pitch swinging lifting it to left
field a arenas behind it grossman will
tag
the throw all the way to the plate not
in time
nice slide by robbie grossman to get
under the tag of francisco mejia and the
tigers lead it 4-1 casey gets a lot of
ground balls and a lot of double plays
turned behind it swinging a miss good
splitter right there at 86.
the one-two and a wave and a miss
back-to-back punch-outs for casey mize
came back and threw an even nastier one
that wasn't even close to the strike
zone these tigers have had success off
him early on so he really had to
make adjustments on the fly
there is a fly ball hit deep into right
center phillips to the wall leaping and
making the catch just before he got to
the wall out by that 382 marker to
retire the side just get this last out
end the inning get in the dugout get
your
g man choi line drive off the back side
of derek holland it trickles to the
right of the mound it was a line drive
right off his rear end doug teeter's
going to come out make sure he's okay
but he's got a smile on his face and his
night's gonna be done i think anyway and
the bases are loaded here's joey wendell
his first pitch swinging to first base
cope get a good toss to hutcheson tampa
keeps him loaded
line drive gonna be caught
wow positioned perfectly a few steps
into the outfield got that glove up
there
to grab it one away
yeah good thing about the positioning
because he didn't have time for any kind
of lateral movement this ball was stung
and guess what right there's brandon
hot shot down to first
joy comes up with it the ball hit pretty
hard and choice stayed right there
stopped it and made the play on the
system yeah a little defense doesn't uh
doesn't hurt either because that ball
was scalded nice play by choi stay right
on it on to the ninth inning the rays
will
call upon david robertson
that's a strike
and valerio caught looking
fine drive that's caught nice job by
walls who was shaded up the middle and
got over there and made the grant
you know what go get the mphs off of
that one because that was an absolute
shot
and taylor walls just takes it in no
problem
boy i'll tell you your chevy play of the
game there it is
that was absolutely blistered 98.2
seemed to be a little bit harder than
that regardless it's a heck of a play by
the ray shortstop being able to glove
that ball off the bat seemingly destined
for a single to center field not so much
and strike three called on goodrem
michael fulmer is here to work the ninth
space has loaded nobody out
first pitch diaz aligner into center
that's going to drop
base hit
margot scores here comes mejia he will
score
two runs score the rays make it a 4-3
ball game diandi diaz on the first pitch
drives in two
wow advanced to second and now it's
four to three
rosarina into the dirt the runners are
going to advance
one of them will
wow goes to third 3-2
fly ball back into center field
tag at third cloud's going to score and
this game is time
serena delivers the sacrifice fly
it's a four-four ball game
another three-two
foul tipped into the glove of haas
[Applause]
nice play right there by brandon lau on
a sharply hit ball by badou gudrum goes
to third that was a run that right there
was a run for the tigers that brandon
lau stole
to two
swinging at a bench 97 at the knees
scope missed it it will be brett
phillips hold for four tonight and the
3-1 pitch
swing and a high fly ball deep to right
field brett phillips has just hit out
and the race win
race win
ray's win go fly it around the bases
brett phillips with a three run walk off
homer and the rays come back and beat
the tigers 7-4
the celebration is on a team meeting has
been called at home plate and salutes
the fans as the rays walk it off
you